who are you you look vaguely familiar
did you spot a special appearance in
cruella because we did
disney loves sneaking references about
character inspirations and other disney
movies into their live-action remakes
whether it's a nod to a famous deleted
scene popular disney landmarks
or fashion moments inspired by the
original here are some of the best
details you might have missed
you notice how some dog owners look a
lot like
dogs when horus and jasper mention how
some owners look like their dogs in
cruella we're treated to two characters
who look almost
exactly like they did in the animated
movie i've never noticed that
the long flowing fur and beret are a
clear reference to this scene
from 101 dalmatians when pongo is
watching out the window to see if he can
find himself
and roger some suitable mates you might
have noticed that the outfits the
partygoers are wearing at the end of
cruella to honor the fallen fashion
designer aren't really that similar to
emma stone's cruella style
that's because they're actually a nod to
another interpretation of the disney
villain
glenn close's version of the character
had the same hair and fashion sense in
the 1996
live-action 101 dalmatians it is rather
amusing isn't it
the woman who inspired cruella deville's
laugh and mannerisms
actually makes an appearance in cruella
while estella is pretending to be a
hotel maid
she's watching the 1944 alfred hitchcock
film
lifeboat starring tallulah bankhead
bankhead was the original reference for
the fashion forward villain in the 1961
animated film
and you can't deny the similarities
between the characters
iconic laughs
[Laughter]
you might notice a nod in maleficent
mistress of evil to aurora and phillips
dance from sleeping beauty
when aurora gets spun around after he
proposes but this scene also gives the
couple their very own little mermaid
moment
there is no magic no curse that could
ever turn me away from you aurora
aurora gets engaged surrounded by
creatures from the moors
under a weeping willow type tree this is
pretty similar to kiss the girl from the
little mermaid where ariel's friends
come together to serenade her and prince
eric
it also teases the little mermaid
live-action movie
take a very close look at the music box
maurice is working on in beauty and the
beast it's a miniature of where he and
belle's mom used to live in paris
but even more subtle this scene also
represents a deleted scene
and character from the animated movie a
deleted story reel from the animation
showed belle
receiving a music box from her father as
a gift on her 17th birthday
a later version of the film even
included a mute music box character who
you can spot
very briefly during the castle battle in
the animation
did you spot the original mulan making
an appearance in the live-action remake
this is ming-na-wen the voice of the
animated mulan
she makes a quick cameo to present us
with the new heroine near the end of the
film
symbolizing her passing the torch over
to the next version of the character
your imperial highness
mulan regents park is where anita and
roger first meet in 101 dalmatians
yeah take mine well according to cruella
the disney villain has a connection to
the very same park
she's particularly attached to the
fountain as that's where she first meets
horus and jasper
and then she goes back regularly to
speak with her late mother
everything's going so well
mum beauty and the beast must have
really loved their music box moments
because one of maurice's other music
boxes features the inspiration for a
disney palace
can you spot the mini taj mahal sitting
on top of a brightly colored elephant
the taj mahal was the original
inspiration for the sultan's palace in
agrabah
it's a pretty fitting detail since the
animated aladdin features a small
figurine of the beast
it's almost like the creators of the two
films were having their own
secret conversation with each other
through references
the outfit estella's mom wears when she
takes her to hellman hall might look
familiar to some of you
it's pretty similar to what anita wears
when she first meets roger in the
animation
she also has the same hair color and
style paying homage to the original
animated character wear it it looks good
when aladdin and jeannie are talking
about the terms of making wishes and
turning into a prince
the magic carpet is having some fun of
his own in the background
if you look closely you'll notice he's
actually building the iconic disney
castle logo in the sand
he even throws some sand over it to
mimic tinkerbell flying by
some of aladdin's unique animation
managed to make its way into the
live-action remake
when genie is explaining wishes to
aladdin he pulls out a scroll featuring
familiar animated versions of genie
sultan and aladdin
it's a perfect reference to the classic
animation style and a quick homage to
robin williams amazing version of the
character
why it feel sheepish maleficent doesn't
turn into a dragon in the live-action
films but
disney made sure to at least reference
the witch's unforgettable transformation
now shall you deal with me oh prince
in this scene her costume looks like it
has scales and even takes on a greenish
hue
a nod to the dragon's epic wings and
green fire from sleeping beauty
aurora is seen wearing a pink dress to
her wedding and you definitely
didn't miss it changing to blue and back
again similar to this scene and the
fairy's disagreement over which color
the princess should wear
make it blue but there's a subtle thing
about one of her other dresses that you
might have missed
this pink dress that she wears to the
dinner party features the iconic
sleeping beauty collar
which was actually elle fanning's idea
mulan's clothes in the live-action film
are often shades of blue and red to pay
homage to the animated character's style
but did you notice the mushu inspired
outfit
in this scene mulan is a troublesome
child wearing lots of red and gold the
colors represent the dragon's colors in
the animation
plus the gold ribbons in her hair and
the way it's styled kinda remind us of
mushu's whiskers
when prince ali is trying to figure out
what kingdom he actually rules genie's
got his back by conjuring a map of
made-up places
if you look closely you'll notice that
the map includes famous disney landmarks
like fantasyland
adventureland tomorrowland and either
cinderella or sleeping beauty's castle
have you lost your country no no
cinderella brought more than one
princess's famous ball gown to life in
the live-action remake
in the background of the ball you'll see
lots of brightly colored dresses
inspired by various disney princesses
there's a bright yellow dress for belle
a green gown for tiana a purple dress
for rapunzel and shades of blue that
remind us of jasmine
what other disney princess dresses do
you spot in this scene
believe me they're all looking at you
when belle and the beast head to paris
there's a landmark in the distance
that's notable from being the focus of
another disney movie can you spot it
what would you like to see first yep
that's notre dame a parisian structure
that just had to be included as a shout
out to 1996's the hunchback of notre
dame
there appears to be a small painting
hanging in the background of this scene
in cinderella that resembles another
disney princess
with a red and blue dress raven black
hair and what appears to be an animal
companion
it seems to be a quick shout out to snow
white whose 1937 debut makes her the
first official disney princess i'm
so ashamed of the fuss i've made if you
look closely at the mad hatter's outfits
throughout the alice in wonderland
movies you'll notice his clothes are
patchwork and look homemade
costume designer colleen atwood took her
inspiration for his look
from a magpie they're known to collect
random things they find
interesting and use them in their nests
suggesting
this is the exact same way the hatter
creates his wacky wardrobe
naughty did you notice the unique shape
of jeannie's boat at the end of aladdin
it looks an awful lot like the lamp he
used to be imprisoned in
now instead of being in his own personal
jail cell the lamp-shaped boat
represents his freedom and independence
i see what you doing you hook me the
live-action mulan isn't a musical but
that didn't stop some musical moments
from being snuck into the new film
the scene where mulan's learning to
fight has reflection playing in the
background and includes a lot of visual
callbacks to the animation
like magnolia trees and mulan seeing her
reflection in a pool of water
another reference is made to all make a
man out of you when commander tongue
repeats a line inspired by the song
prank quit was the forest but on fire
with him
in the lion king timon and pumbaa break
out into an unforgettable cover of the
tokens version of the lion sleeps
tonight
a few lines in pumbaa wanders off into
the trees and timon calls out
i can't hear you buddy back me up well
in the live
action remake he finally gets the backup
he's been waiting for as other animals
slowly join in and harmonize
turning his solo into a captivating
ensemble
clothes this enormous girl the blue
dress that alice wears early on in tim
burton's reimagining of alice in
wonderland is one of the only fashion
moments that echoes the animated film
it was modeled after alice's dress from
the animation and once she changes into
something different it signifies that
this film is going to be
an entirely different take on the alice
in wonderland that came before
to remake the jungle book director john
favreau didn't just find a similar
looking storybook to start the tale
he actually got disney to go into their
archives and dig up the original
leather-bound book from the 1967
animation disney loves starting their
stories off with real story books so
favaro
wanted to continue this trend with the
exact same beginning as the original
it definitely fooled us because we
thought it was just a convincing
recreation
do you notice something different about
casey jr in the animated dumbo versus
the live action remake
it's more than just the colors the train
also has a 41 on the front
this is meant to pay homage to the
original movie which came out in 1941
disney has been known to throw some
hidden mickey mouse designs into the
background of their movies
can you see them in this scene from
aladdin how about this scene from
cinderella
let us know if you spotted them in the
comments down below